avec wohlen phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour palin est donc dans la
presse la victoire annoncée de ferdinand
marcos junior le fils du défunt
dictateur ferdinand marcos à la
présidentielle aux philippines marcos en
passe de remporter une victoire
écrasante de maintenir la times fait
état de la très large avance vous l'avez
évoqué de ferdinand marcos junior sur sa
rivale lenny et robredo selon les
premiers décomptes un résultat que le
journal est tribut à la personnalisation
extrême des élections aux philippinnes
où une poignée de dynasty contrôle à
elle seule l'ensemble de la vie
politique un monopole qui s'exercerait
au détriment d'une très large partie de
la population victime de la corruption
de cette concentration du pouvoir
synonyme de pauvreté et d'injustice
la consanguinité est mauvaise en
biologie elle est aussi en politique
regrette le journal par dino marcos
junior dit bong bong et sa colistière
sarah doute art et de la fille de
l'actuel président rodrigo de tartes et
font la une également ce matin du
philippines délais une quoi erreur
marcos
2.0 après la tragédie la farce le
journal s'interroge sur l'objectif du
nouveau président et se demandent s'il
s'était là à restaurer l'honneur de sa
famille ou s'il se contentera de tenter
de reconstituer sa fortune de mener les
deux mâles et la bottine lui appelle
l'ensemble de la classe politique à
l'unité pour remettre une économie en
marche un qui a été très durement
touchée par les conséquences de la
pandémie à propos de dynastie au pouvoir
et l'aisne en ouganda le fils du
président yoweri museveni qui est au
pouvoir depuis 1986 36 ans se prépare
lui aussi à la succession nada times cet
état de l'ambition de plus en plus
ouvertes de mozika nro gaba d'entrer
officiellement en politique le journal
britannique rappelle qu'en tant que
commandant de l'armée de terre qu'a nro
gaba est accusé d'avoir ordonné
la répression la plus sanglante depuis
plus d'une décennie lors des élections
de 2020 qui menaçait d'en reverser son
père auquel il pourrait donc tenter de
succéder lors des prochaines élections
générales qui auront lieu en 2026 bien
qu'elle ne soit nullement exclusive à
l'afrique où elle a entendu les
tendances dynastique sont bien établis
sur le continent relève le quotidien
britannique qui cite également la
famille bongo au gabon obiang en guinée
équatoriale et gnassingbé au togo mais
pour le coup a assisté seul à la tribune
présidentielle aux traditionnelles
célébrations du 9 mai on en a largement
parlé hier matin en russie vladimir
poutine a assuré n'avoir invité aucun
chef d'état étranger aux commémorations
du 9 mai 1945 une cohue si isolé mais
combative tel est en substance le
message délivré par le patron du kremlin
lors de ces commémorations des
cérémonies sans rien célébrer selon abc
le quotidien espagnol rapporte que
vladimir poutine on l'a évoqué un cet
employé dans son discours a présenté la
guerre en ukraine comme une attaque
préventive je le cite face à la menace
des néonazis de l'otan d'envahir la
russie s'est guère du kremlin qui ne
disent pas leur nom l'ancien combattant
marach gaby doolin les a vécues cet ex
employé du groupe pas la para militaires
russes wagner témoigne ce matin dans
libération des batailles menées par
vagues nerd hall dont basse comme sur le
front syrien selon marc acabit doolin
l'invasion de l'ukraine qu'il qualifie
de faute criminel aurait été pour lui le
déclic qui l'aurait amené à quitter le
groupe wagner au royaume uni c'est à
présent le chef de l'opposition
travailliste qui s'appelle caire steiner
qui risque une amende pour avoir
enfreint lui aussi les règles anti
qu'ovide en partageant quelques bières
hélène avec des membres de son parti
après le parti guette le bill gates à la
différence du premier ministre brian
johnson qui refuse on le sait de
démissionner malgré la controverse la
contravention a figé pour les fêtes à
downing street en plein confinement est
bien pire starmer lui s'est engagé à me
pardonnez moi a quitté sa place de chef
du lait beurre en quête de sanctions une
façon de défier boris johnson sur le
terrain de l'intégrité selon le
financial times qui souligne néanmoins
que ce pari risque de coûter très cher
au patron des travaillistes s'il venait
à être sanctionné le daily mirror le
seul tabloïd favorable aux britanniques
outre manche saute évidemment sur
l'occasion pour faire la leçon à dwayne
johnson voilà à quoi ressemble l'honneur
monsieur le premier ministre si
l'honneur se joue autour d'une pinte est
là ne se quittent pas là dessus l'un
avant de venir à tout à l'heure pauline
je vous propose de rester du côté des
tabloïds britanniques 1 qui ont
décidément le sens d une savoureuse la
déclaration d'un ancien responsable de
la nasa qui indiquait que la
multiplication des découvertes
d'exoplanètes c'est-à-dire des planètes
qui se trouvent en dehors de notre
système solaire suggère qu'il existe
qu'il pourrait exister des formes de vie
extraterrestre et bien figurez vous que
cette nouvelle donne des sueurs froides
catastrophe littéralement le daily star
comme si notre monde n'avait pas assez
de problèmes en ce moment on découvre à
présent qu'il existe probablement une
forme de vie extraterrestre dans notre
galaxie ou dans d'autres avec évidemment
ce clin d'oeil à la guerre des étoiles
et pourquoi pas pauline des
extraterrestres pacifiste bah pourquoi
pas ouais ça nous ferait du bien ça
pourrait être une source d'inspiration
merci beaucoup et l'aisne c'était la
revue de presse à tout à l'heure dans
paris direct